produced with exclusive support from
Illumina this is the story of you
billions of years of evolution and here
you are watching this guy he is Gregor
Mendel an Austrian monk and scientist
hello Gregor in the middle of the 1800s
he's going about his monkey business
breeding pea plants and discovers that
certain traits are inherited as units
that his pea flowers are either purple
or white never a blend of the two never
purple-ish we call these units of
inheritance genes and for this discovery
Mendel is known as the father of
genetics which since monks aren't
allowed to father much of anything is
both naughty and excellent
like Gregor you are built from around 50
trillion cells like him and his pea
plants your cells contain a set of
instructions that you pass on to your
children your genome it's all made of
DNA which carries a code built from an
alphabet of just four letters a T C and
G but there's three billion of them gosh
that's awfully complicated
since Mendel staggering progress has
been made deciphering genomes
here are some other 50 trillion cells
folk Watson Crick and Franklin
discovering the DNA double helix and
this slot figuring out how the code is
translated how and when it's active and
what happens when it goes wrong genomes
certainly are tricky the next chapter in
your story is the human genome project
the entire 3 billion letter code that
makes an average person was published at
the start of the 21st century too great
but not literal fanfare presidents
Harold at the end of disease because
presidents like to do that sort of thing
unfortunately for presidents it's not a
purple and white issue you are more
complex than Peas genetics is not just
about the code it's about how that code
is interpreted how it makes different
cells and different people to figure it
out someone has to look for differences
between people the story of you and you
and you and you and a lot more used to
see how those variations combine and how
they relate to disease
that's what this mob do compare and
track jeans highlighting tiny bits in
the story of you there also inventing
faster ways to read genomes resulting in
explosions of data there we go ten years
on from the Human Genome Project the
next colossal chapter in your story is
the encyclopedia of DNA elements or
encode take about M code is a monumental
step towards piecing together how you
and me and everyone works it's a map
that reveals the whole genome is a
jungle buzzing with activity even the
parts we used to think of as junk not
just the genes but instructions telling
them what to do and when to do it people
and diseases are complex because our
genomes are complex encode hugely
advances our understanding of who you
are where you come from and how genetic
disorders such as cancers or heart
disease happen so that one day they'll
be fixable
so here you are with your 50 trillion
cells and your complicated code that
makes you utterly unique how your story
begins and unfolds is something
humankind is only just beginning to
fathom and that story my friend is a
gloriously colorful thing
[Music]
[Music]
produced with exclusive support from
Illumina